the Joe Rogan experience dude how often
you look up on when you drive and you
see someone on their phone on my shooter
I'm when I'm riding my motorcycle around
town that's all I do is I'm looking in
mirrors and seeing who's not paying
attention but Norton still rides a
motorcycle is about looking down
watching people how crazy is that guy
the key to riding a motorcycle in LA is
to understand that is your job to be
more prepared than everyone in a car I
think I'm also more attention mostly he
rides in New York City yeah he he was a
little more uh he wasn't as kind to
riding in LA as I am I think riding in
LA is not that scary and I think that
because you can lane split here um it
makes a big difference it's safe way
safer to lane split yeah yeah way safer
because most car on motorcycle
collisions are actually rear endings at
lights people can't tell the difference
between the bike in the car and they
crunch them and so if your lane
splitting you move to the front of the
line in traffic and so you don't get
those rear endings the problem with lane
splitting is it sometimes people look
like they're gonna go and change lanes
and look behind them and then when they
lift the motor side out so fast they're
already there well you shouldn't be
going that fast I'll be going that fast
I've seen some guys that are doing some
crazy [ __ ] I know like splits like come
on the law says fifteen differential
fifteen between cars between your speed
on the bike and cars oh well that's not
real I mean that's the law says yeah
except them yeah yeah there's I saw some
dudes the other day on the 4 or 5 that
made me so nervous yeah crazy sport
might be fun yeah crazy sport bike
people will be crazy sport bike people
but that thing if you can manage that
thing one of those [ __ ] your reality
is so different than anybody else
Yeah right you really like sever no
never very little very very very little
I took some lessons but uh two people I
know crashed and got hurt pretty bad and
one of them was a dude who's fighting
for the UFC his name is Frank Mir
he was a UFC heavyweight champion dude
who's got one one of the best guards in
the history of the sport arguably one of
the best submission fighters of all time
in the heavyweight division you know
world champs no fighting or after the
accident no he
but he got hit by a car and got launched
into the air man and he almost lost his
leg you know serious break yeah well if
his car his leg got crunched in between
car and motorcycle engine guts that's
really bad dude he's a gorilla he's a
giant dude no it's a freak him it's
gnarly man
III motorcycling is a very is risky it's
it's for me it's a pretty calculated
risk I'm riding a little scooter when
you ride a scooter versus a motorcycle
you don't get that leg crunch thing
actually and I you know it is what it is
you just gotta you gotta have eyes up
you got to be ready and you gotta be you
know you can't like have a beer then
then ride home you just you could feel
it you can't do it I mean you shouldn't
but even if you you know legally or what
you still shouldn't do it and so it and
also like I love love that I can't pick
up the [ __ ] phone
mmm on that bite that half hour on my
little scooter getting my way through
traffic to wherever I'm going that's a
nice break from the [ __ ] phone and
being able to just be in motion in LA
and you know and you're just going even
if you're going slow ten miles an hour
everyone around you stopped and you're
moving that's the [ __ ] luxury man
that's what I'm about
I'm about being moving when other people
are stopped mmm that's for me that's
what's up might be time to move my feet
I'm like you have to hire a crew your
machine with all its giant building with
all the cars in it and just get out of
here before it blows up it's hard it's a
hard dichotomy Ella if you want to do
the job I have LA is kind of where you
need to be it's the spot right bro I you
know I can get a press car I can get an
800 horsepower supercar press car in
January if I want you can't do that and
impacts more cars than you I've reviewed
over a thousand cars that is so crazy
lot well that's why you developed all
these oddball tastes that's why you have
that wacky Porsche
anterior I mean that's what all that
comes from the kind of the weirdest cars
dude
[Applause]